a new film what is a woman is now the
most successful piece of content that
daily wire has ever produced record
numbers of people have watched it the
film has been trending online for days
it's easily one of the most talked about
and debated films of the year uh it's
been an enormous smash success and
already made i think an immediate and
seismic impact on the culture none of
this would have been possible without
you guys in the audience supporting the
film and supporting our mission more
broadly by subscribing to the daily wire
you know we're trying to build something
so that we can continue making films
like what is a woman and other sorts of
films and pieces of content that will
impact the culture in different but
still important ways so if you haven't
subscribed yet i'd ask you to consider
going to what is a woman.com and getting
signed up we may not have the whole you
know extensive content library of like
netflix not yet anyway but we're on a
mission and we're making art that
matters we're kind of the um the way i
look at it is kind of the scrappy
underdogs the unwelcome
intruders in the subscription streaming
world right now but there's a lot of fun
to be had
in that role that's the good news and it
enables us to make things that literally
nobody else anywhere else could or would
ever make
like what is a woman
now one of the reasons why
nobody would make what is a woman is
because the subject matter is of course
radioactive i mean gender ideology is
the ultimate
third rail it's supercharged considered
untouchable by most people
there are increasing numbers of people i
think who will kind of dance around the
edges of the issue talk about sports
teams and bathrooms and that sort of
thing but very few people will go after
the heart of this thing
it's one thing to suggest that males
don't belong in women's bathrooms
it's another thing to call into question
the actual underlying premise of gender
ideology and transgenderism
the thing is as it turns out even if
you're trying to stay around the edges
it doesn't really work because
you can't make an argument against males
and women's bathrooms without
questioning the underlying premise
if you're trying to keep the underlying
premise intact and say nothing about
that
then you've already surrendered the
entire issue
so that's what we try to do in this film
is go after the underlying premise
premise and because we succeeded so
dramatically in exposing the hollowness
at the core of this ideology
and because we knew we had succeeded we
also knew that
there would be
blowback you know to releasing this
though of course there was never any
thought given to not releasing it this
is a bomb you know in effect
metaphorically and it's a bomb that we
knew we had to detonate come what may
and as for what is coming my way now
there are um the expected things that
we've talked about you know coordinated
campaigns to de-platform me lies and
smears and defamation being spread about
me even to the point of leftists
photoshopping tweets to try to embarrass
and libel me every day i see a new tweet
that i that i never tweeted that's
making the rounds online
um
this was the extent of the backlash
until the last day or two
when the death threats started rolling
in uh we have our security team tracking
those and the police have been notified
might have a little bit more specific
on those uh threats
soon but for now i'll just leave it at
that
um also i should note that i'm an avid
fan of the second amendment and more
than willing to make full use of my
constitutional rights should any of
these keyboard warriors decide to try to
you know try their luck in the real
world
but the death threats are
sometimes not as revealing as the death
wishes and there are
a great many of those on twitter right
now directed at me
most people are most people anyway are
hesitant to make explicit physical
threats
and um the people who have not been
hesitant to make those physical threats
are going to learn why they ought to
have been
but a lot of people are are you know
much more confident and feel a lot
better about especially trans activists
who are some of the most vicious and
cowardly people on the planet
they're not as shy about telling you
what they hope happens to you because i
feel like that gives them a little bit
of cover
so just a few examples i mentioned the
death threats that we've been getting
uh on twitter yesterday i mentioned it
and um and here's how leftists and trans
activists responded i'm gonna read a few
here just a few examples
one says seeing fascist bigots scared
for their life is so satisfying another
hopefully the cops are as effective at
protecting you and your family as they
were at protecting the children and
teachers in uvalde another says you
deserve all of it another says you
deserve worse another says ha ha good i
look forward to hearing how the cops
stood around and watched another says
hopefully some of those threats have
some weight behind them another says uh
rotten hell i hope somebody carries them
out
another one says lmfao hope someone
pulls through when you're actively
discrediting and threatening the lives
of thousands of trans people all over
you deserve to get your
rocked uh another one says
fingers crossed they're credible and you
get the idea hundreds more where that
came from i mean hundreds
they're also posting this stuff in their
own circles online for example one
account posted a fake obituary for me
which said breaking american political
commentator and podcaster matt walsh has
passed away in his tennessee home
further details have yet to be
determined
and i responded to that post with a link
to what is woman.com and they
immediately deleted it another account
posted rt if you think matt walsh should
never enjoy another moment of peace as
long as he lives that tweet had 3 000
likes and i responded to that one with a
link to the website as well and he also
deleted it
there are again hundreds if not
thousands of tweets like this a great
many of them are
apparently without a hint of sarcasm or
irony accusing me of committing genocide
that's their words committing genocide
against trans people
and of course i deserve to die they say
i've committed genocide
with a documentary
my documentary is apparently it's like
that movie the ring you know remember
that in the you know the early 2000s
where if you watched it a monster would
come out of the screen and kill you in
some unspecified but really disturbing
way that's what they seem to think
anyway
but they could find out for sure if they
went to what is a woman.com and became a
subscriber today
now
uh i want to make a just a few points
about this and the first is that there
are some who will sort of dismiss this
by saying that well this is how people
are on the internet
happens on both sides they'll say and
that's that's not totally true i mean
even if it was it wouldn't make it okay
obviously but that's not totally true
yes i mean anyone on any side of any
issue may receive a death threat or two
if they get a lot of negative attention
for
something they said
and yes there are anonymous trolls
posting heinous stuff on both sides
but
anyone who's ever poked the gender
ideology beehive
knows that trans activists are uniquely
vicious and feel especially entitled to
say and do whatever they want
let me ask you something what if there
was someone out there who kept a log of
every single thing you did every minute
of the day um you know i think that'd be
pretty creepy if that would happen well
what if i told you that's exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider like at t or comcast
is allowed to store
logs of every website you've ever
visited and can legally sell this data
to anybody that's why i always use
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
server so your internet provider can't
see or log what you do online now many
of you might be wondering well if i'm
routing all my data through a vpn that
doesn't just you know that then doesn't
that just mean that the vpn can see what
i'm doing and log my data instead
and you're right to think that many vpns
claimed having no logs policy but have
been caught logging customer activity
anyway well expressvpn the good news is
it's the only vpn i trust because they
use trusted server technology they were
the first major vpn provider to engineer
all of their vpn servers to run in ram
this me this makes it impossible for
their vpn servers to store any data
including logs of any expressvpn
customer and you don't have to take my
or expressvpn's word for it expressvpn
is so confident and they're no longer
claimed they've even had one of the
biggest insurance firms pwc audit their
technology so this is very
something you know you can trust stop
letting people keep logs of what you do
online visit
expressvpn.comwall show right now and
find out how you can get three months
free
as someone who has a lot of experience
poking various beehives including
literal beehives as we talked about
yesterday um i can say for sure that no
group is quite like the trans activist
in this regard
i mean even take like blm we know what
blm is willing to do
well i've said a lot of things and done
a lot of things to upset blm and i've
gotten the blow back for it but it's
never quite like this
so why is it like this with the
left-wing trans activist well it's
partly because they're amoral
narcissists
partly because they've been emboldened
by social media platforms and by every
other institution to act out in whatever
that way they they want without
consequence
and it's partly because
as previously mentioned
they've told themselves this delusional
story and been told this delusional
story
that anyone who criticizes their
worldview is a clear and present danger
to their very physical existence
one trans activist summarized this
delusion quite well in response to my
tweet about the death threats i received
and it said here's the thing
we trans people are not prepared to be
removed from society the fact that you
were prepared for death threats means
that this is an operation a planned move
to kill us
you are inciting violence we are backed
into a corner with a knife to our throat
you see with my documentary i have
backed them into a corner with a knife
to their throat
and this gives them the moral right to
kill my whole family
they really believe that
at least they want to believe it and
they've worked very hard to fool
themselves into taking this kind of
delusional hysterical nonsense seriously
this is the consequence by the way the
the
intended consequence of the words are
violence
nonsense
because it empowers people like this it
gives them the excuse
to be even more vile and vicious than
they were already inclined to be
it's also the consequence of our
societal obsession with
affirmation
you know these activists have come to
believe
that they have a god-given human right
to be affirmed
that is to have everyone in the world
agree with them
and reinforce their self-perception and
they are so convinced of this notion
that when they encounter a non-affirming
opinion or thought or film
they take it as a threat to their lives
they don't know how to not be affirmed
right like most of us i i encounter
stuff all the time that doesn't exactly
affirm me and my beliefs so i just
that's part of life
i don't break down into tears over it
i don't take it as
um it's gonna kill me like there are no
words you can say to me that the words
themselves will kill me
but over here this is the attitude
they don't know how to operate in a
world that is anything less than 100
affirming all the time everywhere with
no exceptions hollywood makes hundreds
of movies and shows every year that
suck up to them one film is released on
a platform they aren't even subscribed
to which takes the opposite approach and
they feel it gives them moral license to
murder the person responsible for it
when i say the left wants you dead i
mean i say it from experience and it is
actually true
and that brings me to my final point and
i want to be very
clear about this to the people who are
posting these things and making these
threats first of all you don't scare me
your ideology is a threat to society to
children to women
to all people
to reality
i'm never gonna stop pointing that out
or fighting against you and against
everything you believe
this reaction only cements me even more
in my convictions it radicalizes me even
more than i already was and i didn't
think that i could be any more radical
about it
and it makes me even more convinced than
ever that this film is necessary and
important
and i'm so happy we made it
couldn't be happier
and i'll tell you this
the more you keep this up
the more offensive my next film is going
to be
you're doing this to yourselves
actions have consequences
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends